If you've been wondering whether anybody is
president of the United States right now,
you're not alone. Donald Trump hasn't
had a public event in a long time.
If you look at Donald Trump's official schedule,
you'll see no public events dating back four
weeks. Trump occasionally meeting with Mike Pence.
R officials are signing something in private,
but he's been missing. And yesterday, this right
wing college organization called Turning Point USA
did an in-person super spreader event with the
likes of such right wing tours of intellectual
force as Dave Rubin, Eric Bolling and three
female Republican Congresswomen elect and Donald
Trump called into the event through the organizer
Charlie Kirks cell phone or a cell phone handed
to Charlie Kirk. And it is absolutely bizarre.
So let's look at the clips first and then I'll
talk a little bit about just the downfall of the
office of the presidency over the last few months
and years, they seem to have staged some kind of
interruption. While Charlie Kirk was speaking,
some kind of flunky comes out holding a cell phone
for Charlie Kirk and has to interrupt, Charlie,
because it's so important if you are allergic
to cringe, I would skip the next 40 seconds.
I cringed really hard when I saw this.
What I want. Charlie, then
I'm so sorry. I know you're
in the middle of speech.
This can't wait. I would never do this to you.
But this is something. And we cannot on this.
Hello, who's there? Charlie, how are you?
That sounds like a big crowd of beautiful people.
What a surprise, guys, it's Trump anyway. Let's
listen to what Trump actually said. And remember,
Trump has been doing nothing for weeks other
than figuring out ideas for how to steal the
election. But this event, he calls in to take a
listen. And, of course, Trump starts talking about
how he needs the Justice Department to do
something to steal the election that he lost
and again asserts that he won the election. Quick
reminder, Donald Trump did not win the election.
That sounds like a big crowd of beautiful people.
We have high school students here
to hear from you and our Student Action
Summit, and I thank you for calling in.
I mean, we have your back 100 percent,
by the way, 100 percent. I know you do.
I know. I know. Charlie, I
appreciate it. I appreciate everybody
there. I've spoken for Charlie numerous times
and we've always had a great time. And we are
fighting really for the country because this
election, we won this election in a landslide,
brought hundreds of thousands of dollars to the
state. It's all documented. The problem is we need
a party that's going to fight and we have some
great congressmen and women that are doing it.
And we have others, some great fighters. But
we won this in a landslide. They know it. And
we need backing from like the Justice Department
and other people to finally step up. But I just
want to thank Charlie for the support. Charlie's
always been there. I watched you the other night.
We won by a lot. He says, of course not. True.
And this is really a crowd that will cheer
for anything, truly, I imagine thinking
that you're building a solid fact based
organization that is willing to cheer wildly when
Trump lies and claims he won an election that he
obviously lost significantly. Now, just one other
little moment that shows you really just how dumb
these right wing figures think the crowd is.
This is not about this is more a commentary
about the organizers and the speakers than it
is about the audience. Charlie Kirk casually
mentions Trump took time out of his busy day
negotiating the stimulus to talk to this crowd.
Look, this is why we love our
president. He's he's in Washington,
D.C., negotiating the stimulus bill. And but
he wanted to make sure that he talked to you.
Most people would realize that that's
completely patronizing and ridiculous,
especially the idea that Trump is negotiating
anything that's laughable. But sadly,
this type of stuff really works on people because
the Magga cult is is very it's just bizarre. And
when I was watching these these clips, it brought
back memories of documentaries I've seen about
evangelical Christian youth conferences where they
indoctrinate kids into evangelical Christianity.
Sometimes it's specifically sects that fall
under the umbrella of charismatic Christian
churches. These are the ones that sometimes speak
in tongues. Sometimes it's Pentecostal. Anyway,
there's lots of interesting documentaries about
these types of churches. A Jesus camp is one in
which our good friend Mike Papantonio actually
plays a role. But that's what I was reminded of as
I was watching these videos. They seem like these
evangelical indoctrination camps that people that
kids are sent to. These are just slightly older
kids effectively is what's going on. Really sad
stuff. And again, Trump missing for weeks from
the public. This he calls into. Unbelievable.